We have already seen the characteristics of
images formed by plane mirrors.
The image is of the same size as the object.
And it's also at the same distance away from
the mirror as the object is.
And the image follows left-right reversal.
It means that the object's right is the image's left
and vice-versa.
And lastly, the image formed by a plane mirror
is a virtual image.
So what about the images formed by concave mirrors?
Do they have the same characteristics?
You all must have seen the reflection of your
face in a spoon. Spoon has two smooth surfaces
one curved inside and the other curved outside.
However, it is not perfectly spherical.
For ease of understanding, we can consider
the reflecting surface which is curved inwards
as a concave mirror.
I will show you how the image appears,
but using an actual concave mirror and not a spoon.
So let’s try and find out the properties
of an image formed by a CONCAVE MIRROR.
I will show you two views of the mirror.
The front view and the side view.
The side view is just to show the different positions
where the object is kept, as it's difficult to
do that in the front view.
Ok, so let ‘P’ be its pole, ‘C’ its centre of curvature,
this line is the principal axis and the ‘F’ is the principal focus.
Also called focal point.
Assume that initially, the object is kept close to the mirror.
I will make a table on the right, with three columns
telling us the where the object is kept,
the size of the image formed and
the nature of the image, that is whether
the image is virtual or real.
So initially the position of the object is between F and P.
What is the size of the image?
We see the reflection in the concave mirror
and the image is BIGGER in size.
We see that it's ENLARGED.
The dimensions of the image are greater than the dimensions
of the object!
So we say that when the object is between
the principal focus and the pole, the image
formed is ENLARGED.
Also is the image is upright or erect?
What about the nature of the image?
Is it real or virtual?
Yes, it's the virtual image!
It appears to be formed BEHIND the mirror!
Where is the location of the image?
It is a virtual image, so it does not have any location!
It only appears to be formed in a location behind the mirror.
But we will find that location in our next video using ray diagrams.
For now, let’s move this object away from
the mirror and see how the dimensions and
the nature of the image vary relative to the object.
You will find that as I move this object away,
its image gets even bigger.
And when the object is at the principal focus,
the image is HUGE.
We say that when the object is at the principal
focus, the image is HIGHLY ENLARGED .
Is it a real or a virtual image?
It is a real image!
Since it's a real image, it's upside down!
Or we use the other word for it which is INVERTED.
It is formed on the same side of the mirror
as the object is.
And believe it or not, the image is actually
formed infinitely far away!
When I start moving this object away from
the focal point towards point C, the image
is still enlarged but the size is reducing.
And what is the NATURE of this image?
Yes, here as well the image is upside down, it's a real image.
When the object is at point C, the image
is still real and inverted but now the size
of the object and its image is same.
Yes, at this point both the object and the
image are of the same size!
What next?
If I move this object beyond point C,
the image remains real and inverted, but now the
size of the image is actually smaller,
compared to the size of the object.
So we say that the image is DIMINISHED.
This is also a real image.
As the objects keep moving beyond C, the size
of the image keeps on reducing.
What if the object is placed at infinity?
Well if you remember that in our previous video,
we saw that the rays of light parallel to
each other as well as to the principal axis
will converge at the focal point.
And in that example our object was the sun.
Sun is at a very large distance away from
the earth and hence we consider the rays of light
from it reaching the surface of
the earth to be almost parallel.
The image of the sun will be formed at the
principal focus.
Similarly, if any object kept infinitely far
away from the mirror on the principal axis,
all the rays from it can be thought of as
travelling parallel to each other.
After reflection, they will all converge at the focus.
And the image of that infinitely far away
object will be formed at this point.
Yes, this is a point sized image!
It is a highly diminished image and is also a real image.
Take a moment and go through the properties
of images again.
From this table you can see that the image
is virtual ONLY when the object is kept between
the focal point and the pole!
Otherwise the image formed is always a REAL image.
In the next video we will find out the position
of these images using RAY diagrams.